a girl loses the love of her life in a
tragic accident but death will not stop
her from being a toxic girlfriend today
on cinema recapped i'll show you
the in-between from netflix
spoilers ahead watch out and take
care the movie begins with a car
accident in which a couple are involved
the girl named tessa wakes up in a
hospital and is told that they managed
to save her but that her boyfriend died
182 days before the accident tessa was
at her parents house when she suddenly
decided to go out to take pictures on
the beach
later tessa goes to the movies where she
meets a boy who is the one from the
accident the two decide to watch a
romance movie together and when it
finishes she tells him that the best
romance movies are the ones that don't
have a happy ending they leave the
cinnamon say goodbye tessa realizes that
she left her jacket in the cinema so she
returns for it and realizes the boy
named skyler also forgot his cap
in the future after the accident tessa
is in the hospital when suddenly she
sees the boy who is supposed to be dead
he tries to show her something but just
at that moment tessa wakes up realizing
that it was just a dream
tessa explains to the doctor what she
saw but she tells her that it was just a
nightmare the doctor also explains that
due to the accident she suffered a
rupture in her heart and that she died
for a moment but they managed to revive
her and heal her heart
that night tessa was feeling very poorly
in the hospital when she suddenly starts
to hear the boy's voice as if he were a
ghost
the next day tessa speaks to a woman who
supposedly knows about ghosts
tessa tells her that she's been
listening to skyler and the woman
explains that perhaps the boy is a ghost
and that he's there because he still has
things to say to her and that tessa must
answer his calls so that skyler can go
in peace
tessa decides not to believe in that and
just at that moment her parents pick her
up because apparently she's good to
leave the hospital in the past 102 days
before the accident tess's teacher tells
her that she has a lot of potential to
be a photographer that maybe she should
take more romantic pictures
which makes tessa wonder what she loves
tessa starts to think more and more
about skyler and one day while taking
pictures for some athletes she sees him
again
tessa decides to go over and give him
his cat back and the two start talking
very happily since they didn't believe
they would find each other again
at that moment skyler's mother appears
and she tells tessa that her son has not
stopped talking about her that he was
even looking for her days after seeing
her at the movies
later tessa and skye decide to go for a
walk together and then they go to an
abandoned museum that used to be for
newlyweds
they walk around the place and tessa
takes some photos then they both decide
to sit down and talk and end up kissing
skye takes tessa home and they agree to
meet again at the end of the month to
spend the whole summer together
in the future
tessa is very sad over the loss of skye
she talks with a friend and explains the
strange events that make her think that
skye is close although the friend
doesn't believe her
later tessa goes to school and there the
teacher tells her that soon she has to
submit a portfolio with her best photos
to get into a good university but tessa
doesn't seem interested in that anymore
tessa decides to go for a walk and
starts to remember all the photos she
took of skye
so she ends up very sad and decides to
throw her camera into a lake
later she returns home and decides to
throw away all the material she used to
develop her photos
and tells her father that she's giving
up photography
that night tessa goes to sleep and
dreams that skye hugs her and tells her
that he's still there when she wakes up
she's very surprised and begins to
believe that skye is giving her signs
from beyond the grave
at that moment tessa hears sounds in the
room where she developed the photos she
decides to enter and realizes the
machine is printing a photograph
tessa decides to take all her materials
out of the trash and with these she
begins to color the photograph realizing
that it is a photo she took when she
went to the museum with skye tessa is
quite amazed and decides to put another
sheet in to see if the machine prints
another image then
as there is no response she decides to
approach and inadvertently places her
hand on the sheet
the machine prints an image and when
tessa goes to color it she realizes that
her hand was printed but that skye's
hand also appears intertwined with hers
although the image fades after a few
seconds
tessa convinced that skye is sending her
signals decides to go see the woman in
the hospital but realizes that she has
already left although at that moment the
doctor tells her that the woman left a
book for her tessa starts reading the
book and learns a lot about the
afterlife and also finds out that some
cameras can capture ghosts
in the past tessa and skye have a date
but skye is sad because his parents are
going to divorce tessa tells him that
sometimes that happens in relationships
but skye replies that he doesn't believe
that since he believes the couple should
fight for their love
another day
tessa and skye go for a walk and tessa
tells him that her father abandoned her
when she was a baby and that later when
she was a girl her mother also abandoned
her
she was at an orphanage until her
current parents adopted her as a
teenager the next day tessa and skye go
to a lake to take some photos and then
they row a boat skye tells her that he
loves her but tessa doesn't respond
the two decide to go back to the car
uncomfortable but just at that moment
tessa decides to kiss him passionately
and they end up making love in the
future
tessa talks to her friend about the
photographs that appeared in her room
but the friend tells her that it's
impossible
the two girls have to take an exam but
tessa sees that her pencil moves on its
own and that it begins to draw some
lines
tessa is very surprised and at that
moment all the students cell phones
start playing tessa and skye's favorite
song
seeing this tess's friend decides to
believe her about the signs of sky
in the past sky takes tessa to museum
and there he shows her that he displayed
a photograph that she took and that
there are several buyers who want to
acquire it at a very good price tessa
gets angry with him for having put a
photograph of hers up without her
permission to which sky tells her that
he did it so that she could see that
people admire her photos and that she
should enter a prestigious university
that is also close to the university he
is going to
and therefore
they'll be close at hand
tessa doesn't listen to him and they
just end up leaving in anger
later tessa feels guilty so she sends a
message to sky to meet him although he
replies that he can't tessa goes to talk
to her adoptive mother and explains that
she had a fight with skye to which her
mother replies that she should tell him
in person that she loves him
in the future tessa and her friend try
to communicate with sky through a pencil
also through mirror and a television but
nothing works
tessa goes home disappointed but just
when she arrives she notices that the
gps of the car suddenly indicates an
address and that this address coincides
with the lines that the pencil drew at
the time of the exam
tessa decides to go to the address and
when she arrives she meets the woman
from the hospital who was talking about
ghosts
the woman tells her that if she wants to
communicate with sky she must look for
the place where the most love between
them arose
but that she must be careful because
once she crosses the portal between life
and death there will be no turning back
in the past
days after the fight tessa and skye meet
again at a party and there tessa looks
for the right moment to tell him that
she loves him however she ends up
realizing that skye is going to another
university that's on the other side of
the country tessa gets angry with sky
because she thinks he wants to abandon
her sky responds that he's going to that
university to be closer to his father
since he's not feeling well to which
tessa could only reply that she needs
him too skye tells her that she can't
understand him since she doesn't have a
family which makes tessa angrier and she
breaks up with him
in the future tessa goes to all the
places where she spent time with skye
and takes photos of herself with a
special camera to see if skye's ghost
appears in one of them
tessa finishes her trip in the museum
and sitting in the place where she had
the first kiss with skye
she sees a light in a mirror on the
ceiling
suddenly tessa begins to walk up the
wall inching closer to the mirror upon
reaching the mirror she sees sky on the
other side both of them try to break the
barrier but they only end up breaking
the mirror the connection ends and tess
ends up falling to the ground
then tessa's parents find out that she
went to the abandoned museum so they
scold her
and just at that moment
tessa faints
they take her to the hospital and the
doctor tells them that her heart wound
is reopened they will have to operate on
her the next day
tessa hearing this tells them
desperately that she has to go because
she knows that she only has a few hours
left to meet skye again however the
doctor does not listen to her and only
sedates her
later tessa wakes up and decides to call
her friend and tells her that she has to
meet up with sky as soon as possible the
friend decides to go to the hospital and
take her out without permission
both girls get into the car and suddenly
it starts driving on its own until it
takes them right to the place where the
accident occurred
tessa gets out of the car to see if she
can find skye and just at that moment
she faints then tessa's soul leaves her
body and begins to see what happened
there the day of the accident
we see that tessa went looking for skye
and when she found him she told him that
she loves him so tessa is very happy
because she did not remember what her
last words for him were and it makes her
happy that she could tell him that she
loved him
at that moment the ghost of tessa sees
the ghost of sky and together they hug
happily and begin to travel together
like two souls in love
they go together through many places
they both wanted to travel when they
were alive and at one point tessa sees
that her body is now in a hospital with
her family waiting for her she decides
to say goodbye to skye and both agree
not to forget each other
tessa returns to her body and revives in
the real world
weeks later tessa presents her
photographs that she took with sky to
try to enter the most prestigious
university and continue her career as a
photographer
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best romantic movies
thanks for watching